en el último vídeo aprendimos que una
elipse puede ser definida como el lugar
geométrico de todos los puntos donde la
suma de las distancias a dos puntos
especiales llamados focos y permítanme
dibujar todo esto entonces este es mi
eje x la suma de las distancias a estos
dos puntos especiales llamados focos o
puntos focales es una constante
entonces si éste es mi elipse la voy a
dibujar que se vea más o menos donde
quiero que esté justo por ahí se ve más
o menos bien está centrada en el origen
no tiene que estarlo pero para nuestros
propósitos hagamos la centrada en el
origen si este es un punto focal justo
aquí y este es el otro punto focal
este elipse se podría definir como un
conjunto de todos los puntos o el lugar
geométrico de todos los puntos donde si
yo tomo la distancia de cualquiera de
estos puntos que existen en la elipse a
cada uno de los focos si tomo esa
distancia y la sumo a esta distancia
entonces vamos a llamarlos vamos a
llamar a este de 1
este es de 2 que eso va a ser igual a un
número constante a lo largo de toda la
elipse entonces si tomo un punto al azar
vamos a tomar otro punto a lo largo de
la elipse digamos que tomó ese punto de
aquí y si yo sumar a esta distancia si
sumar a esta distancia a esa a esa
distancia
vamos a llamar esta vamos a llamar a
esta justo aquí de 3 y esta es de 4 la
suma de estas distancias a los pocos a
lo largo de esta elipse va a ser una
constante entonces en este caso de dos
más de uno esté más s va a ser igual a
de tres más de cuatro
más de 4 y esto va a ser verdad a donde
quiera que vayas a lo largo de toda la
elipse y aprendimos en el vídeo anterior
que esta cantidad en realidad va a ser
igual a 2 a donde a es la distancia del
radio semi mayor
si esta es la fórmula para la elipse de
aquí es de donde proviene la equis
cuadrada sobre a cuadrada más de
cuadrada sobre b cuadrada es igual a 1 y
aprendimos que los focos la distancia
focal o la distancia desde el centro de
la elipse de la elipse que es esta
distancia justo aquí esta distancia
focal es justo igual a la raíz cuadrada
de la diferencia de estos dos números
entonces es solo podemos decir que esta
es la distancia focal de aquí a acá es
sólo igual a la raíz cuadrada de
si es más grande entonces sería cuadrada
menos cuadrada que es el caso en esta
elipse si tenemos una elipse vertical y
realmente no lo cubrí en el último vídeo
pero déjenme solo mostrarles cómo se
vería digamos que la elipse se ve algo
como esto déjenme ver muy bien usaré
azul
digamos que la elipse se ve algo como
eso en este caso nuestro radio se me
mayor está ahora en la dirección y
entonces esto es esto es ve esto es ah y
en este caso ve es más grande que a
cierto porque la elipse es alta y
delgada
en este caso los focos los focos siempre
estarán en el eje mayor en este caso el
eje mayor es el eje vertical así que los
focos quedarán aquí y aquí y en este
caso las distancias focales van a ser
verticales desde el origen hacia abajo y
verticales desde el origen hacia arriba
y tenemos en lugar de ser a cuadrada
menos b cuadrada ahora como ve es más
grande que a la distancia focal que es
ésta va a ser igual a be cuadrada menos
a cuadrada
muy bien ahora hice todo eso para más o
menos compararlo con lo que vamos a
cubrir en este vídeo que son los puntos
focales o focos de una hipérbola y una
hipérbola es es muy parecida a una
elipse probablemente podrían podrían
adivinarlo porque si esta es la ecuación
de una elipse esta es la ecuación de una
hipérbola x cuadrada sobre a cuadrada
menos ye cuadrada sobre de cuadrada es
igual a 1
o podríamos intercambiar estos donde el
menos está frente a la equis en lugar de
la ye y podríamos cubrir eso en un
segundo pero esta hipérbola se ve algo
como esto
déjenme ver si puedo dibujarla
si dibujo los ejes
y luego yo quiero dibujarlas asiento
estás podrían intentarlo podrían ver
algunos de los vídeos previos pero las
cintas para esta hipérbola van a ser
y es igual
más o menos ve sobre a por equis así que
se van a ver solo dibujaré estas como
líneas inclinadas así que se verían algo
como eso
y algo como eso esas son las cintas pero
estas están centradas en el origen
porque no han sido desplazadas y
entonces esto es lo que yo llamo un tipo
de hipérbola horizontal la forma en que
pueden pensarlo es bien si resuelve para
y verán que siempre van a estar un poco
por debajo del asiento está la otra
opción es y dicen bien pueden x oye ser
igual a 0 bien sí que es igual a cero
eso nos pone sobre el eje x cierto y
obtenemos x cuadradas sobre a cuadrada
es igual a 1 entonces sí que es igual a
cero tenemos x cuadrada sobre a cuadrada
es igual a 1 lo que significa que x
cuadrada es igual a a cuadrada lo que
significa que x es igual a más o menos a
entonces los puntos a 0
como 0 y el punto menos a menos a 0
están ambos en esta hipérbola y como
tienen a más o menos ser contenidos por
estas asín todas nunca pasan por ellos
saben que esto va a ser una una
hipérbola que abre hacia la izquierda y
hacia la derecha así que se verá algo
como esto dejen de usar este color así
que se verá algo hoy esta es la parte
difícil se va acercando y acercando a
ese lado y luego pueden ver esto como
uno de los vértices de la hipérbola y va
a ir más o menos así donde esta
distancia y noten la semejanza aquí con
la elipse esta distancia justo aquí
déjenme hacer esto en un color más
llamativo esta distancia justo aquí
entre estos dos supongo que les podría
llamarlos los conos de las doce elipses
esa distancia justo ahí esto es a
y esto también está así que tienen una
distancia de 2 a que es muy similar a
esta situación donde esta distancia es
ah y esta distancia es
así que la distancia entre los dos
puntos a la izquierda y derecha en una
elipse horizontal es la misma distancia
entre los dos puntos a la izquierda y
derecha en la hipérbola es sólo que la
hipérbola abre hacia afuera mientras que
la elipse abre hacia adentro
muy bien pero todo el punto de este
vídeo es discutir los focos como se
podrán haber imaginado y lo toque un
poco en el último vídeo que la hipérbola
también tiene focos pero ellos abren
ellos van a estar a la derecha ya la
izquierda de estos dos puntos entonces
esto es a dejen de hacer los déjenme
hacerlos en un color más brillante
porque quiero que puedan verlos digamos
que esos dos son esos son los focos y
una hipérbola esto es noten la
diferencia una elipse una de las
definiciones de una elipse era el lugar
geométrico de todos los puntos o el
conjunto de todos los puntos porque la
distancia de cada uno de los puntos la
suma de la distancia de cada uno de esos
puntos a los dos focos es una constante
ahora la definición de una hipérbola una
de las definiciones de una hipérbola
puede ser el lugar geométrico de todos
los puntos donde tomándola la diferencia
no la suma tomás la diferencia de las
distancias entre los dos focos
así que déjame escribir eso así que esta
es de 1 y esta es de 2 así que tenemos
una situación aquí y vamos a tomar
podemos tomar el valor absoluto de la
diferencia porque puede haber puede que
para algunos puntos de uno sea más
grande que de dos si están sobre esta
curva pero si están sobre esta curva de
uno será más pequeña que de dos
así que de 1 - de 2 el valor absoluto va
a ser igual a una constante en la
situación de la elipse de 1 más de 2 era
una constante así que están relacionadas
estrechamente están en la elipse estamos
tomando la suma de las distancias a los
puntos focales y decimos que es una
constante en una hipérbola estamos
tomando la diferencia de las distancias
a los puntos focales y decimos que eso
es una constante así que este número
justo aquí va a ser exactamente la misma
cosa que si tomo un punto justo aquí y
estoy escogiendo estos puntos
arbitrariamente siempre y cuando estén
en la hipérbola y si llamo a estos dos
puntos llamamos a este
y t4 la diferencia entre de uno y de dos
es la misma cosa que la distancia la
diferencia entre de 3 menos de 4 esto va
a ser una constante a lo largo de toda
la hipérbole entonces la siguiente
pregunta es que va a ser igual esta
constante y aquí es donde es es útil
encontrar un punto donde es donde más o
menos puedes tener la intuición y lo
hicimos con las hélices donde dijimos
si tomamos estos puntos utilizamos la
lógica en el último vídeo para decir oh
la distancia entre la suma de las
distancias entre esto y esto
esa suma va a ser igual a
vimos va a ser igualados a es la
distancia del eje semi mayor cierto
porque esta distancia era la misma
distancia que esta distancia así que
esto más esto es lo mismo que esto más
eso que es 2a cierto
así que todo el tiempo las constantes la
suma de las distancias a los dos focos
era igual a 2a y ahora en la hipérbola
cuál es la diferencia de las distancias
a los dos focos así que tomemos este
punto justo aquí sobre la hipérbola y
estamos diciendo así que cuál es cuál es
déjenme tomar un buen color cuál es la
distancia magenta qué es la distancia a
ese foco menos esto déjenme escoger otro
color menos esta distancia azul claro
esta distancia magenta menos esta
distancia azul claro
así que podemos hacer un argumento muy
similar al que hicimos en la situación
de la elipse esta distancia azul claro
es la misma está la distancia de este
vértice o de este
supongo que saben este punto más a la
izquierda de esta hipérbola que abre
hacia la derecha a este foco es la misma
distancia que esta distancia porque la
hipérbola es simétrica alrededor del
origen o la distancia focal es la misma
a cada lado del centro de la hipérbola
dependiendo de cómo lo vean pero creo
que eso es un un ese no es un gran
argumento para que ustedes lo acepten
así que si esta distancia es la misma
que esta distancia entonces la distancia
magenta menos esta distancia azul claro
va a ser igual a esta distancia a esta
distancia verde cierto y esta distancia
verde es que estos a vimos eso al
principio de este vídeo así que esto es
una vez más es también igual a 2 y de
cualquier manera los voy a dejar aquí
por ahora
de hecho bien para vamos de hecho a
hacer un problema más solo porque me
gustaría hacer uno concreto
porque les dije al principio que si
ustedes querían encontrarla digamos la
así que sí tienen una elipse así que si
ustedes y esto es una elipse x cuadrada
sobre a cuadrada más que cuadrada sobre
b cuadrada es igual a 1 aprendimos que
la distancia focal es igual a la ra es
cuadrada de a cuadrada menos b cuadrada
ahora para la hiper fila ustedes ustedes
más o menos ven que hay una relación
estrecha entre la elipse y la hipérbola
pero es más o menos algo divertido para
reflexionar sabe y la adecuación de una
hipérbola se ve como esto x cuadrada
sobre a cuadrada menos que cuadrada
sobre b cuadrada es igual a 1 o podría
ser que cuadrada sobre b cuadrada - x
cuadrada sobre a cuadrada es igual a 1
y resulta que les voy a probar esto en
el siguiente vídeo es un problema de
matemáticas pesado que la distancia
focal de una hipérbola es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de la suma de estos dos
números es igual a la suma de cuadrada
más b cuadrada así que si yo les diera y
noten que la diferencia es solo la
diferencia en signo están tomando la
diferencia de esos dos denominadores y
ahora están tomando la suma de los dos
denominadores
así que si yo les diera a ustedes la
siguiente hipérbola x cuadrada sobre 9 -
que cuadraba sobre 16 es igual a 1 bien
la primera cosa que hacen es aunque yo
nunca bien podríamos descifrar la
distancia focal solo conectándonos a la
fórmula la distancia focal es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de a cuadrada más b
cuadrada donde esto es a cuadrada
cierto a es 3 b es 4 así que 916 es 25
lo que es igual a 5
y si fuéramos a graficar esto déjenme
ver ese es mi eje y ese es mi eje x es y
la distancia focal es la distancia a la
en este caso a la izquierda y a la
derecha del origen si fuera del tipo del
perb o la que abre hacia arriba y abajo
sería por encima y por debajo del origen
así que esto es
así que las dos así en total esto está
centrado en el origen no ha sido
desplazado van a ser 16 sobre 9 así que
van a ser unas muy empinadas así en
total se van a ver algo como eso
eso esas son las a síntomas los dos
vértices están en dos veces a estrés
cierto a cuadrada es igual a 9 b es
igual a 16 así que esto es centro así
que los dos vértices este estrés
y este es menos 3 y entonces los puntos
focales van a estar en 5 desde el centro
a la derecha así que estará justo aquí
entonces ese es 5,050 y menos 5,0
este es menos 3 y este es 3
entonces si fuéramos a graficar lo se
vería algo como esto
ahí tienen y si tomarán arbitrariamente
un punto sobre esa hipérbola y toman
esta distancia y sustraen esa de esa
distancia entonces sería un número
constante que sería exactamente igual a
2a o exactamente igual a 6 en este
particular ejemplo de cualquier manera
en el siguiente vídeo les probaré esta
fórmula lo que es un poco de álgebra
intensa pero es divertido a pesar de
todo